>>> JUST IN TO CNN, A U.S.
DIRECT COURT JUDGE HAS RULED
AGAINST LINDSEY GRAHAM AND HIS
APPEAL TO TESTIFY.
THE FULTON COUNTY DA SUBPOENAED
HIM.
>>> JUST MOMENTS AGO THE JUDGE
ISSUED A 22-PAGE RULING THAT
READS IN PART, QUOTE, THE COURT
FINDS THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY HAS
SHOWN EXTRAORDINARY
CIRCUMSTANCES AND A SPECIAL NEED
FOR SENATOR GRAHAM'S TESTIMONY.
JOINING US NOW TO SPEAK ABOUT
ALL THIS IS PAGE PATE, CRIMINAL
AND CONSTITUTIONAL LAW ATTORNEY.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU ON.
I SUPPOSE THE FIRST QUESTION IS,
CAN SENATOR GRAHAM APPEAL?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
SENATOR GRAHAM, I THINK, HAS
ALREADY INDICATED THROUGH HIS
OFFICE THEY'LL CONTINUE TO
CHALLENGE THIS.
IF SO, THEY HAVE TO SEEK
PERMISSION TO CHALLENGE IT IN
FRONT OF THE 11th CIRCUIT COURT
OF APPEALS HERE IN ATLANTA.
>> THIS IS COMING AS RUDY
GIULIANI HAS ALSO BEEN ORDERED
BY ANOTHER ATLANTA AREA JUDGE TO
APPEAR IN PERSON, I BELIEVE,
THIS WEDNESDAY BEFORE A SPECIAL
GRAND JURY RELATED TO THE
INVESTIGATION IN ATTEMPTS TO
OVERTURN ELECTION RESULTS THERE
IN GEORGIA.
HE HAS SAID HE IS NOT ABLE TO
ATTEND AND CANNOT TRAVEL.
WHAT DO YOU EXPECT THE JUDGE TO
DO IN RESPONSE TO THAT?
>> WELL, I THINK THE JUDGE IN
FULTON COUNTY HAS ALREADY
SUGGESTED TO GIULIANI THAT YOU
NEED TO FIND A WAY TO GET DOWN
HERE.
I THINK THERE'S EVIDENCE THAT
HE'S BEEN ABLE TO TRAVEL TO SOME
EXTENT, BUT REGARDLESS, THE
JUDGE HAS ALREADY CONSIDERED
THOSE ARGUMENTS AND SAID, YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO TESTIFY.
IF YOU CAN'T FLY, DRIVE.
IF YOU CAN'T DRIVE, GET ON A
TRAIN.
WHATEVER YOU NEED TO DO TO GET
DOWN HERE.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND,
THESE ARE TWO COMPLETELY
SEPARATE CHALLENGES.
SENATOR GRAHAM WENT TO FEDERAL
COURT AND RELIED ON THE
CONSTITUTION IN ARGUING THAT,
HEY, YOU CAN'T CALL ME IN TO
TESTIFY BECAUSE WHAT I WOULD BE
TALKING ABOUT WOULD BE
PRIVILEGED INFORMATION AS PART
OF MY LEGISLATIVE DUTIES.
THAT FEDERAL JUDGE, JUDGE MAY,
REJECTED THAT ARGUMENT
COMPLETELY AND SAID YOU STEPPED
OUTSIDE YOUR ROLE WHEN YOU MADE
THESE CALLS TO THE SECRETARY OF
STATE IN GEORGIA.
ON THE GIULIANI SIDE IT'S A
FULTON COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT
JUDGE.
HE'S NOT ABLE TO RELY ON THE
SAME TYPE OF CONSTITUTIONAL
PROTECTION.
YOU HAVE TWO DIFFERENT JUDGES IN
TWO DIFFERENT COURTS HEARING
CHALLENGES TO THE SUBPOENAS.
BOTH OF THEM SO FAR HAVE SAID
THESE WITNESSES MUST APPEAR.
THE ONLY QUESTION NOW IS WHEN
AND WHAT QUESTIONS WILL THEY
HAVE TO ANSWER.
>> IT IS MIND-SPINNING AND
UNDERSTANDABLE IF VIEWERS AT
HOME ARE CONFUSED AT THE NUMBER
OF INVESTIGATIONS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY ONGOING IN THAT STATE,
GIVEN WE'RE LIKELY TO SEE AN
APPEAL FROM SENATOR GRAHAM, HOW
LONG COULD THAT LAST?
>> THAT'S UP TO THE 11th
CIRCUIT.
THEY COULD TAKE IT ON AN
EMERGENCY BASIS, WHICH IS HOW
SENATOR GRAHAM FILED THE INITIAL
CHALLENGE IN FEDERAL COURT.
THEY COULD HEAR IT VERY QUICKLY.
IT'S LIKELY THEY WOULD, IF THEY
ACCEPT THE APPEAL, DELAY HIS
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE SPECIAL
GRAND JURY AND ALLOW BOTH SIDES
TO SUBMIT WRITTEN ARGUMENTS AS
TO WHY THEIR POSITION IS
CORRECT.
IT'S AN IMPORTANT ISSUE BECAUSE
IF THE SPECIAL GRAND JURY IS
ALLOWED TO ASK SENATOR GRAHAM
ABOUT QUESTIONS RELATING TO WHAT
HE TALKED ABOUT WITH FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP, THEN THAT COULD
CONCEIVABLY GET INTO LEGISLATIVE
MATTERS.
BUT IT'S ALSO CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS COULD BE THE BASIS
FOR A CONSPIRACY CHARGE OR A
RICOH CHARGE HERE IN GEORGIA.
IT'S A CRITICAL ISSUE.
>> LET'S GET BACK TO THE FULTON
COUNTY INVESTIGATION.
YOUR TAKE ON THE SPEED AT WHICH
THE INVESTIGATION IS GOING AT
THIS POINT BECAUSE WE SHOULD
NOTE THAT PRIOR TO THAT RAID
LAST WEEK AND THAT SEARCH AT
MAR-A-LAGO, THIS WAS THE
INVESTIGATION THAT MANY LEGAL
EXPERTS SAID THE PRESIDENT
SHOULD BE MOST CONCERNED ABOUT.
>> YEAH, I AGREE 100%.
I THINK WILLIS WAS WELL AHEAD OF
THE FEDERAL INVESTIGATION, AT
LEAST BASED ON WHAT WE SAW,
BECAUSE HER SUBPOENAS HAVE BEEN
MORE OUT IN THE PUBLIC BECAUSE
THOSE WITNESSES HAVE CHALLENGED
THEM IN COURT.
WE DIDN'T KNOW WHAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE WAS DOING
IN CONNECTION WITH THIS
CLASSIFIED MATERIAL UNTIL THE
SEARCH WARRANT WAS EXECUTED AT
MAR-A-LAGO.
NOW, EITHER SIDE COULD PULL THE
TRIGGER FIRST, OR NOT AT ALL.
IN FULTON COUNTY BECAUSE OF
THESE CHALLENGES TO THE
SUBPOENAS, IT'S GOING TO TAKE
THAT SPECIAL GRAND JURY A BIT
MORE TIME TO HEAR FROM THESE
WITNESSES.
REMEMBER, IT'S A SPECIAL GRAND
JURY, SO THEY CAN'T INDICT
ANYONE.
THEY CAN ONLY MAKE A
RECOMMENDATION FOR INDICTMENT.
ON THE FEDERAL SIDE, AFTER THE
RAID WAS CONDUCTED, THE SEARCH
WARRANT WAS EXECUTED, THEY NOW
HAVE EVIDENCE ARGUABLY THAT
CLASSIFIED MATERIAL WAS HELD AT
MAR-A-LAGO.
NOTHING PREVENTING THAT CASE
FROM MOVING FORWARD.
>> PAGE PATE, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BREAKING IT DOWN FOR US.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
>> THANK YOU.